but is this Meek Mill this is the [ __ ]
yeah
Meek Mill is free you like this gym but
yeah it would like sit back and listen I
love this well welcome back that's the
melodic tones of Rob Bennington gracing
us with Rhonda good but this is nice
yeah Ron is good huh this is nice this
is nice I love Ron but I really love
this yes also this is not the first time
Jim's spoken of his love for the song
it's really weird do you listen to this
song Travis never but you will now now I
mean I have to it's part of my job but I
won't it's like a film inside of a pop
song it's everything lazy love that
knocked up in it the father wants to
kill the guy dumps her in the middle of
the night [ __ ] great
if it isn't that like every single
country music song ever some are tell
you this is gonna get stuck in
somebody's head yeah we're banking on
yep
congratulations are in order for Ron
banks I totally forgot until they told
Ricky congratulated you off fair but for
Gayle oh yeah that I'm gonna be a
grandfather that's amazing yeah it uh it
feels like a weird accomplishment of
somehow but I arrived alive yeah I know
I know when you think back over there
like how many people don't get to live a
life you know and I'm talking about a
very good friend of mine John F Kennedy
jr. he was my buddy I was his wingman
I'm sorry I don't know you were supposed
to be on that plane yes I was yeah thank
you for remembering that Jim I supposed
to be on that plane I used to call him
deuce at that time he was my goose Wow
no it's just great that you're like you
know I I don't know why I'm so proud of
being a grandfather maybe it's because I
could have ended up like JFK jr. by the
way he's to come JJ no a lot of people
go john-boy but not john-boy that's odd
is it weird you look back on though I
think there's Willie Nelson we're
supposed to be on the Buddy Holly plane
one of them was supposed to be on that
plane and didn't take the and you
sided to take that right at the coast I
believe it was yeah I think it was
Waylon Jennings oh well yeah here's what
happened and I think was just one of
them like Big Bopper Ritchie Valens said
I have a cold can I get in and well it
says you know good because I I do
codeine so the trip goes by fast for me
no matter what that crazy yeah how
[ __ ] it what a [ __ ] decision one guy
made and how lucky but that's your whole
life you don't know how many times have
you not realized how close you came you
know that's what I think like it when
things are bad or what I'm really
depressed or when things suck I'm almost
like yeah but you never get to see the
movie the other way like the one time
that my file I looked at a text message
it didn't cross the street and get hit
by a dump truck right and I could have
been [ __ ] into a bag from the time I
was 31 on and never you know I have no
idea that almost happened I do that
anyway I find it convenient the best
part is when you [ __ ] into the bag and
then you swing it at your friends yeah
and you don't throw it but you just
tease oh my god this thing's gonna burst
so you feel are you excited to be a
grandparent yes I am you are I'm very
excited them get go ahead yes as it a
done anything thinking about your
mortality or anything like that your
context of what a grandparent is well
not until right now yeah even if I
wasn't a grandparent just I'd be the
same point in my life the immortality is
there like I said you you you know I
have mortality things because I see
people all the time around me dying
death is everywhere Roth is everywhere
and that and I had that as a kid I grew
up in Cambodia I used to call him Paul
reefer I went to the killing fields
elementary school and our team was
called the Khmer Rouge and we were good
gypsy cynthia's don't wonder no wonder
you want to do a tour with Colin let me
tell you what this city was like who
knows that remember it was so great oh
my story his New York story this was my
favorite part and I had
in my neighborhood and he said that
black girls would always have two kinds
of candy they wouldn't just be eating
one kind of candy they would have like
licorice and sweet tarts at the same
time I'm like how could that have been
univer by would I get that right man he
has the ability kala it's a weird
ability as a stand-up to just explain
how it like to say something like that
and know that everyone will get it and
even if people don't get it they do it
like you almost you're in all of the
observation as well as enjoying yet
don't like well he didn't do it in this
once one of my favorite Colin jokes was
he was talk about how black people have
been taught not to trust this system
right where when you're on the platform
and you'll say to this it's a black guy
you like hey he's the - train stopping
and they'll go it's supposed to like and
you understand immediately why that is
he's just he's so [ __ ] great man the
other thing that he did that was just
amazing to me he was talking about
Italian guys and they would fight
anybody and they have you know a trash
can full of bats they would always know
where the bats were right but then they
would be afraid of things like you
shouldn't be like and he was said like
if that when frozen-yogurt came out they
were like eh hey just back in a way and
the thing that was also so funny is the
way he was walking like a young Italian
yeah what like an athletic Italian kid
would walk yeah well Colin in a way does
believe himself to be an athlete which
is his real downfall he does believe
he's athletic any boxes he can play
basketball no he's really nice he's
really not I see
no he's not he's the body like a Stella
Getty you know who are the the comics
that could be athletes
depalo played college [ __ ] did you
call about de pollo yeah rogon obviously
was an athlete it was Bill burr plays
hockey
denis leary plays hockey men Bailey he
strikes me as athletic yes Ben's an
athlete right a runner because he's tall
and you know in good shape to me well
Ben looks like a 1930s
NFL player leather helmet days I was I
used to fight yeah why you gotta throw a
punch you go away you had to slow that
down for us if it's honest - SHhhh
we're at Wednesday and this is the third
day in a row this week that he's fit in
it you know it's been more just looking
go dude didn't you see the way you
blocked it no juice in that Sarah on
filter two right now so Matt's out yeah
I went for dinner last night I had
[ __ ] pretzels and frozen yogurt
yeah and I'm going to fart a lot don't
be late for dinner yep I was like a
child you already have farted a lot yes
you several times so you're gonna be a
grandfather grandbaby yes
in July oh by the way there's not a lot
I have to do here you know supportive
that'd be supportive and and lie you
know honey like you lie to children what
like how yeah you just tell him that the
past was better than it was you know a
man like back then we used to get you
know free soup and you know whatever is
gonna believe I remember being a little
kid and my great grandmother or
grandfather would talk about being
little and I would think they were lying
I couldn't imagine them young yeah I
just knew you were that cynical that you
really but as a little kid you're like
yeah they're lying yeah I was just
having one of their bad candies that
they would have it there I like those
green leaf things or whatever and I'd be
thinking why right you're gonna start
doing that are you gonna start having
bad candies and doing grandparents yeah
ain't gonna find some of those things I
don't even know where you get it
there were me butterscotch is acceptable
I think the alibi disguise yeah you do
what did you when you were younger is it
just something that's an acquired taste
hobbies an acquired to you I think it
always have those weird like almost they
look like barber poles they do a red and
white stripe their temperaments happen
but they weren't peppermint oh there
were another weird flavor yeah they were
not good I don't know where they found
because you're a little kid you were an
expert in candy right you know you know
every candy except for grandmother candy
right I don't know where you get that
and even though it was bad I still ate
it
I still like yeah all right I'll take
actually put on a dish a hard candy it's
like hey look you leave one of these
every three days you can't what're you
doing
when you get so bored you get so bored
that you're just eating you're just
eating hard candy yes because it's
something right that's what I got to
figure out is how not to be boring right
now to really put together a decent set
that the kids gonna like would you have
a favorite age I mean obviously you've
been through it so you know what it is
like do you have an age of the grandkid
because you're just gonna get the best
parts not the worst parts so do you have
an age that you're like okay this is no
spot no I don't have those kind of
expectations I like babies or like
toddlers they're like little kids
I like teens and they're awkward years
where we have to go everything sucks
here this really I find nothing funnier
than that awkward child it's just
growing too fast
yeah and they say stupid stuff right
like they kind of are starting to take
the shape of an adult but the things
coming out of their mouths are so
uninformed yeah and also you're right
when you when as soon as that base drops
you know you're all of a sudden say to
your kid what the [ __ ] are you talking
[ __ ] Cheston up with me and right
right cuz they're gonna like you
whatever that you challenge but it's the
same goods the same it's the same child
want some peanut butter suddenly it
occurs you there's a man in your home
right yeah you're starting to grow a
little late rash - do you like do you
like the guy she's having the kid with
yeah really really good Joe yeah he's
also a Philly guys from Upper Darby it
makes out that yes it's me she's just
got him freed in time for this so it's
really wonderful wonder you were so
psyched yeah do you know one Meek Mill
song I know I know that Drake so well I
know Prairie dogging prairie dog
I know that the songs that he and Drake
went back and forth with and they really
humiliated him with that but I do enjoy
the humiliated Hill meek why Drake did
much better in the rap battle all he did
yes were they against each other
yo yeah all they don't sound like a
comedy roast is that what we roast
battle
you don't like there's no part at the
end where you go but I love this guy one
of the lines like you name is meek but
you are not humble I like that so you
can rap III can rap slam I can lift you
up when I'm rapping you ever you want I
want what your name is meek and your
mother's Greek pull out your nipple
she'll give it a tweak we can go all day
so she can't speak
Daniel rap lyrics no I thought I'd
celebrate a generational gap well have
one Travis this I have one of its this
is a bigot
Drake disses yeah oh you want you you
want to hear the Drake diss how do I
talk about the party I lie and rap it
I'm talking about going to the party and
I was thinking about you you should hear
the other wives you hear J Cole's new
song that's exactly what you want cool
not talking about partying he's Sam's
dead oh why would you I like to hear
nobody even mean right Travis enjoy Rob
wants to laugh at you and he didn't but
I like to hear them rap about their
recent purchases yeah do you know a lot
of money do you have got I like to find
out the degree of somebody's success by
them displaying it yeah how about you in
a convertible with a bunch of girls with
fat asses please somebody no I want to
just hear them read off their American
Express receipts I was here the heavies
here's everything I got I would listen
to that yeah let's hear at the party
this is what this is his big club oh
good thank God duck club yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah
so far no we means so far not a good one
it is he like he must have sex with the
girls in the bathroom maybe do drugs to
[Music]
see this is fine yeah yeah yes I do
he's a hot boy you know that Nikko
leaked emails a hot boy he bucks a lot
of girls and he gets a lot of money yes
I guess when I hear this and I do enjoy
it I don't want to hear comedian get one
ounce of [ __ ] for anything they say
that's all of them bothers me but you
like when he goes
instead of putting his finger in front
of his mouth he put the money wanna cash
I like this view yeah I like that meat
melts of [ __ ] here comes the course I
get it you know why you like it because
they're not talking about being in the
club because they're at a house party
but here's the thing if it's a house
party why is he [ __ ] her in the
bathroom when I just take her up to his
room
it's a house party let's be respectful
to the to the owner yeah but there's
always a guest room [ __ ] in the
laundry room before you're in the
[ __ ] I think you can find a better
room [ __ ] it I think that should maybe
be your new bumper sticker I do have one
how come none of these guys sing about
other stuff what they do one of these
like like rappers no I'm not how about I
try to put it in but mine I lost my
erection she picked my nipples I was
embarrassed and I made up an excuse it
just sounds like a unique experience oh
it's not doesn't ride it just applies to
but how about something like that have a
self at the house party
you forgot drunken [ __ ] and puked
behind the bookcase what's something
that happened to the house party they
were ever bad that stuff I mean it's
just not popular neighbors are
complaining yeah they'll say that mom's
coming home yeah here's the that's Newt
dog said it sits and my mama ain't home
I was ever hass down well you seem like
you know the history of rap guys here I
was thinking that for likes not raining
to us
oh yeah he he didn't do well in his in
his rat beef with Drake he just
destroyed him there
but yeah Drake looks like [ __ ] to me
right now exactly now it's all love for
me are they friends no no why did they
like each other
well Drake's from Canada he is a
Canadian yeah but you know what he said
what he said I'll tell you what he
summers and this is rough this is real
tough for him to come back from you know
Meek Mill and Nicki Minaj were an item I
didn't know they're not anymore right
not anymore what happened they broke up
ah but Meek Mill was was used bragging
about how many people he performs in
front of because Meek Mill and Nicki
Minaj were on tour together as an item
Nicki Minaj is the more popular rapper
of the two I'll say
and Drake said is that a world tour or
your girl's tour oh Jesus and I mean
that at home there was no coming back
absolutely that's what people have said
to boss over the years he's had to deal
with the same as [ __ ] yeah so he gets
the pain yeah yeah so that was the start
of it that we know I don't know that's
what ended it Meek Mill was upset with
Drake because Drake wouldn't tweet about
a song that they did right so that's
kind of what started the beat well I was
right do it he's not trying to do that
it's his tweets are very very valuable
isn't drink a little oversensitive
didn't he call somebody ask him why they
didn't like him Drake is a little no we
like him
yeah yeah Drake called Peter Rosenberg
my buddy yeah cuz Peter Rosenberg member
that video that we were criticizing on
the air where he's giving out money to
poor people for his music video yeah
Peter Rosenberg was on hot 97 and he was
like saying that you know it was kind of
like what we were saying that it was
coming to call us a little bit setup I
don't know if we have the reach we
cantle yeah okay
but yeah Drake called he can hear us in
Canada Drake called Peter and said that
he was really upset with him and like
why would you do this I did something so
positive why would you put a negative
spin on it you just called him on the
phone not on the radio just on his like
cell phone would ya the call I'm on
herself did you ever hear the big song
who does about my whole crews here or
something like that did you hear that
about the whole crew right there
yeah yeah the whole gang and I are
piling around still to this day yeah no
I remember you don't know I hate the
break in the middle of the guy [ __ ]
the skit stupid it's not in the real
rappers stop doing skits on the [ __ ]
records nobody wants to hear it what
these nothing to do it on the record you
just know I know but if they do it on
their stay they will have them on their
records what do you say what you keep
saying they all rappers that that hold
on now I take meant blacks yeah yeah I
mean I'm sure the audience because most
of his audience a big trump supporter
sure I'd say that guy goes out on a limb
yeah you know doesn't care about come in
the other direction though Kid Rock is
straight Kanye went in the other
direction
yeah Konya did I do like that he did
that time is the rebel he's the one is
going like no I love Jeff
what does can you do now though wait
he's coming out with new music no is he
yeah cuz I know we wouldn't try to be a
fashion designer he's doing that to I
mean but it's done I suppose
his shoes are like the most popular
things out I had no idea they are you
see his new muffin shoes are terrible
which one's the [ __ ] the ones that
look like something you wear in the ER
oh yeah there's dog [ __ ] ones those are
the easy 500 terrible have you seen his
muffin shoes there's like fat muffins
yeah yeah the easy 500 I just just out
Drake just called Meek Mill pepper mill
that's I think what they call my gosh
yeah is that what's that short for yeah
he said you may be my won't inherit the
earth who goes back yeah yeah but let's
go back to these [ __ ] fat new ers
they're horrendous there they are the
easy 500 they literally look like
something you put on on a [ __ ] on a
fake leg yeah it looks like a burn
victim would wear medicine soles every
step yeah everybody's that little
medicine squeeze that'll be a burn feet
yeah there's good as I select New
Balances well you like my new bounce it
but admittedly minor comfy and awful
those are no better than when I'm
wearing on my feet but these costs 120
and those probably cost two thousand you
think that I'm gonna get a pair yeah
why must be making that wrong Bennington
pretty good you know I guess those
ticket sales are not too bad at the
stand you better get those tickets now
cuz clearly they're gonna sell it's all
about this dress factory this week oh
the stress factor yeah but I know you
call yourself a broadcaster but you just
went for the wrong gig you do the stand
too right I forget that that has nothing
oh okay headline money is different I
see I see
yeah I have one pair of those easy shoes
I haven't I have a few person to muffin
ones Troy the white ones yeah they say
there's no Easy's it's the same ones
except they're nerds let me see the
nurse shoes just like the yeah yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] that's the thing the kramer
war that's the guy who was yelling oh
yeah they're all ridiculous terrible
yeah and they sell out of every single
they do that yeah [ __ ] heroin sells
out to it doesn't mean I would put it on
my feet does make it a good show he's
right biohazard shoes type of thing you
won't win the government in a movie like
releases a toxin right they have to
[ __ ] hook but you can't walk up a
wall with it yeah he's always ahead of
[ __ ] I've been on the habit ahead of the
coma fat shoes for a long time that's
true what's the difference in those in
mind those are slightly nicer than mine
come on they look like mine and why do
we say that Kanye is a head of [ __ ] he
was the last person to [ __ ] him you know
I mean like he came in certainly that
was a great counterpoint thank you he
came in late yeah everything else he has
been ahead of the curve but with Kim
Kardashian he was a little bit behind
well give me what he was ahead of the
curve because musically he's ahead of
the curve every single time he puts out
an album how yeah I don't understand he
just one baby [ __ ] that's not that
nobody else we disagree I know because
you don't lose ik no I do I hear the
same song over and over it's right
completely hey I got a bunch of [ __ ] I
bought a diamond ring and we're in an
earring look at my hat look what's going
on with kiddin play that's what I'm
curious about right Philly guys right I
don't know whether for LA I don't know
if you're seriously asking what I want
to know boy got a head look like a
whisper what was Robin's last name that
can Williams Oh Harris thick the comic
that was Robin Harris yeah hilarious
yep just the funniest man yeah there
they are now oh my god presents they're
working and the Kanye previously [ __ ]
yes Kanye West the other shoes he put
out the 350s Jerry's yeah this Kanye
West this Yeezys at Jerry's yeah those
shoes were like now do these sound more
than athletes shoes I mean - they're
more people getting these shoes and a
basketball player
you lose ones yeah can I get a pair for
400 300 off my pair yes I'll start them
by the way you know who [ __ ] does
that is boss boss well I'll see him with
the young comics and he'll just have his
phone and he's just whipping through
different shoes that way it's amazing
how would how wrong is priorities like I
know I'm an [ __ ] yeah but when you
see his dumb [ __ ] his dumb dwarf
fingers with those rings on it you show
a picture of Voss's fingers with rings
on it and see this oh it's horrible I
literally like turtle feet his hands are
enraging what you don't think that a
good voice should be drawing attention
to his fingers with no with the Rings
how about with rings so I put rings
across rings fingers yeah yeah rings
yeah he's decided that instead of
investing in stocks and bonds and things
like that he's gonna buy jewelry now go
to there was a close-up of his [ __ ]
double god damn it where is it look
believe it or not you know rich voice
hangers are not like this big Google
about this small it should be by the way
why would anybody think that jewelry is
gonna be worth more money cuz when you
go to a pawn shop you know I mean it's
not worth [ __ ] yeah if I don't know I
mean I don't do any jewelry if you
back to the jeweler or something no I
don't think of rings as clock Elvis's
rings maybe somebody might want to have
a TCB ring was broken he's a broken
person and he's doing that because he's
a broken person he wants to show off
that he's doing well so he drives a BMW
and he wears rings on his little teeny
fingers then at the end of the day
exactly right living the hip-hop
lifestyle that's where I respect him
because he's not like you guys going
like on all these songs sound the same
Voss is like no I'm down yes I'm cool I
would love to do a thing can you tell
what song that says I just play rap
songs and to the artists themselves in
it but they have to say whether it's
their song or somebody else's I think
that's mine sorry Ron let's play that
game right now can you tell what song
this is that's a trick because that's
the Osmonds and what a job they're doing
which one are you well I'm gonna always
be with Marie Osmond she was abused as a
child and now she's selling sport
against her she never says but I believe
it was a record producer oh yeah she was
huh yeah and she brings it up so you are
a little bit country then yeah in this
case only because I'm with with with
Marie who by the way what are these [ __ ]
this guy in Toronto who with the van
yeah what is this [ __ ] group of
douchebags the they're in in cells in
cells yes they can't get laid [ __ ]
come punch you guys I can't get [ __ ]
running mad at women of course they are
it's therefore it's not the guy's fault
ah but here's the thing if you think the
look the guy who's a pretty good-looking
guys an average looking guy that normal
yeah
but the young people don't understand I
brought this up yesterday you got to be
able to lay down a but every once in a
while you know I mean you're just not
swinging for the fences so you're gonna
find a Wallflower girl you know they all
want to sleep with a porn star the hot
girl and then they're furious right find
a girl that is gonna be happy to be in
this situation right you have to know
exactly where you rank
and you oversee every single time shoot
lower always that's the right thing for
you and they're so desperate they come
off as creepy and aggressive like you
will go out and it's like or just you
know a [ __ ] like you said yeah hit on
somebody who you don't you're not as
attracted to or just go out to dinner
and don't try to [ __ ] her like about
these guys are the worst by the way this
guy big wrestling fan they said is that
right and that's weird because most of
the pro wrestling audience is
extraordinarily sexually at the incest
Italian has begun we're gonna overthrow
the Chad's and Stacy's all hail the
supreme gentleman elliot rodger a lot of
chance and Stacy's like the the Barbie
and Ken's a bunch of Troy Kwan's of the
world yes yeah exactly it by the way if
I overthrow them I just don't want you
just accept that you're rejected what a
bunch of [ __ ] little [ __ ] because
it's not it's it's involuntarily selfish
their fault it's the chance in the
Stacey's fault yeah not me that I'm
unfuckable I've you know as much as I've
been mad at women in my life cuz I
haven't gotten what I've wanted I always
know it's because I'm unfuckable that's
weird self-loathing isn't doesn't come
naturally for you no I know but I make
myself do it so again this is another
problem at the end and I started because
the guy would just think of himself as a
loner right and now the loners are
bitching about to each other right
because that's what yeah because it's
easier you can find other loners to kind
of back up no you're right no it's them
no you're right and you can find comfort
in that group and I'm totally celibate
yeah yeah killing strangers you know I
mean that's the thing that I think
anybody understands though that got
[ __ ] with me or even they have money
that I'm trying to take off of them but
I'm gonna go kill strangers my matically
world it's all of them and they try to
make the police shoot him what I what a
little jizz bag just a turd just a
little turd and you know they're gonna
be great
did they did they kill him no but they
should have but what's great about money
he goes to jail for life he will never
have sex with the way that I did think
about irony yeah
he will I don't think I'll die a virgin
but he will never have sex with a woman
in so they just got to belong to even
guys and aren't getting [ __ ] want to
belong to something worse they want to
belong to us and is it one of these
things worse younger people who are
taught that you're supposed to be
getting I know yeah I'm not saying it's
generational but is it one of those
things where everybody gets a trophy and
then you look at the pretty girl as a
trophy and I can't have
like are they getting hit with reality
that no you're not always great you're
not always gonna get what you want right
so they don't know how to handle the
reality here's something weird though
when I was a kid everybody played they
gave us a trophy I don't know why
everybody acts like it's know we all got
trophies no matter what I did get
trophies there were second place
trophies too I think I mean it just
participation trophies yeah you're on
the team I guess a very small worthless
trophy yeah that gave me one in the lady
when I ran a mile for finishing in the
late 80s I was on teams that everybody
got trophies yeah everybody always got
the entire league in fifty and 1950
everybody got a trophy yeah I don't know
why we just made it up now right well
now there now these kids are acting like
they deserve a trophy I don't know why
coach kids before and they just like no
thanks for the trophy but they did say
we get trophies I'm like AB but he's got
a trophy okay but they look up through
the [ __ ] inside they look up to
elliot rodger he couldn't get laid he
shot himself that's their hero I would
sometimes don't play those sports just
because I wanted the trophy knowing that
I wasn't good I put no effort into it
and I grow like I've really liked what
was the sport I did soccer and two
seasons is like first grade of t-ball
hmm I wouldn't even any good at tea I
couldn't hit a ball on a tee well how
about this if they want to teach kids
like everyone doesn't deserve a trophy
how about this no one gets one why even
have one even if you're the best player
look what is it the same things every
but that's the point nope I'm saying
which that's the point I'm making is how
about what there's nothing important
about a trophy then how about nobody
gets one out they're saying that you
there needs to be winners and losers but
you you'd have to be no dependent that'd
be a full-grown man and still have your
Little League trophies out yeah yeah I'm
sure my mom threw them in the trash
yeah worthless except for two like a
young boy who was like look mom I got a
trophy put him in your room up until
like third grade
I really wasn't good a t-ball anyway I'm
saying if that mentality is real yeah if
they're like hey everyone should get one
fine then why not no one get one look
it's the endless of those I would like
to say in the Olympics nobody's getting
a medal right [ __ ] it
yeah I thought you won you you came in
first why do you didn't melt like what
is that represent that's true it's cool
whenever good said to somebody give you
a medal no they really do
I'll tell you one thing Ron not to be
corny but those set those laughs when I
see the smile of a child that's a medal
when you see a smile of a child you're
in trouble that's a good point why do
you get rings for winning exactly Super
Bowl exactly anybody should get things
and you know the point I'm making is if
that thinking is true because they're
saying like everyone should get a trophy
so participation how about then the same
thing is if there's no meaning to then
no one should get one like why even give
them out if they don't mean anything but
here's the thing there are good trophies
and they're not so good trophies like
everybody gets a report card but it
doesn't mean it could be a report card
you could be proud of right yeah I got a
I got a see on a report card and my dad
took us all out for pizza like let this
guy do the order and he's the Einstein
miss to see yeah yeah it's also
perspective right there's not a
universal this is a good or a bad trophy
report whatever it's like what do we
really expect from little Ronnie like if
little Ronnie comes home with a see it
is a time for celebration it was I mean
I've gotten by awards for bad thing it
is with it what did you get no words for
most likely to whip an elderly person
give you a trophy it did yeah was the
cowering old person anyway the hammer
don't take that out of context oh yeah
laugh before laughs after yeah hashtag
free Nick by the way suspension by the
way before Nick I think would have been
a suspension yeah they didn't need to
fire Nick I mean come on he took the
[ __ ] tweet down yeah what do you want
and the insane ages are no room for a
mistake mmm
like it wasn't a smart tweet he knows he
shouldn't have the word it that way
sometimes you word something poorly when
you're firing out jokes in a public
forum yeah it happens you know you're
firing out silly thoughts you don't mean
it literally he doesn't really want
people to go in and behave that way no
so he fires out a dumb joke it happens
chrissake and now somebody literally
said then he highlights all right that
was a gotcha but he took it down the guy
he went like I [ __ ] up to get done
what do you want from the guy that's
what's crazy yeah I'd love for the
person who who ratted out Nick like the
Twitter snitch to be like hey look at my
accomplish by the way none of us would
have even heard about it
without that person none of my mean I
didn't even know what happened until
yesterday when somebody called up and
said and Nick is saying it publicly so
it's one of those things I was like you
said it privately and someone taped him
but it's the idea that somebody did it
to just like look just a weiner thing
it's a weiner thing to do
alright I made a mistake turning in the
tweet I'm sorry suck up to Jim Meier hey
have you heard what's going on office
gossip I told him yesterday Sam was
eating in front of a guest you gotta
know how to categorize are you guys
getting a gonna guess that you like is
we've got a note we're happy to have you
yeah we have hanging up a little bit
this who's a make up Hank Azaria was
then we didn't get him honey wings and
we're not getting we didn't get Jason
Biggs yesterday we didn't get W kamau
Bell
who are we getting these are great guys
though well we're getting on Friday we
have two ten o'clock 10:00 a.m. Friday
is when our booked guests starting Lee
tomorrow we've got Adam Paley coming in
in mark Normand Sam Moreau yesterday
yeah our friends we are friends will
come in of course but I think Jason
Biggs and
Jenny Mollen it was their people saying
like this project doesn't really fit the
show which I mean I don't think that
people ever say that I don't think they
said Ken how many shows can you put my
people I really don't say Cheech and
Chong wouldn't do our show I mean
what yeah first they would yeah of
course yeah Cheech and Chong would and
Hank Azaria would hey guys area's not
getting here until like 10:30 10:30 yeah
but snow he addressed the controversy
did who controversy yeah yes so stupid
well stupid deal but when I was a kid
people used to call my dad a PO South
Asian I'm sorry I try to keep up with
the times
yeah yeah no you're right now I'm
getting woke from you but did you guys
see that thing I didn't realize that
although every South Asian comics their
dads got teased by being called a pool
and they saw it when they were kids it
never even occurred to me I get you know
I mean when I was a kid do you people
would definitely get teased and called a
poo yeah BZ called anything when you
write but Jesus don't blame you can
Blayne cartoons because people are
Cantus an adult cartoon whether Wow yeah
I mean a little bit you know I do think
it's the kids cartoon kids were watching
it back then kids aren't watching
anymore they don't care anymore
when I was a kid we watched the cartoon
[ __ ] and we thought it was fine
turned out it was it move on hey by the
way when you watch cartoons did you ever
[ __ ] hit somebody with a wrench when
you watch the Stooges or an issue
no wonder saying like kids were jumping
out the window in the 1950s because
Superman could fly like I think a lot of
stuff is urban myth I think it's not
that stupid to think the first of all
you take off from the ground you don't
you're not a kite you're a [ __ ]
superhero you almost the other on the
heavy set was afford the generation
before the Simpsons it was Jonny Quest
and and you know Indian kids were called
[ __ ] yeah because that was the character
on Jonny Quest right
but kids you take a [ __ ] cuz there's
less of them right that's the big
problem
I'm sure if you grew up in Pakistan
people would be teasing you Sam I would
hope now no they were teasing you in
Westchester yeah sure I wouldn't I would
never Universal yeah they were what days
I said well for a while I was a short
kid but then I took HGH so it wasn't
short anymore but then I still had a big
head and was just awkward as hell man
you were like a baby face kid you mean
you looked young oh yeah yeah I mean I
saw that video of you that time and I
was amazed on Nickelodeon yeah yeah I
mean I looked you that's why I gave you
14 he was cute because I wasn't I mean
it's cute for eight at 14 you'd cry for
them I don't know if I was 14 yet yeah
but it was 12 or 13 yeah but well yeah
so I was like I look like a little kid
until I graduated high school pretty
much how old were you there doctor I
mean that's probably like 12
Robbi 13 that's stunning to me yeah
stunning but that says did you shower
just the school you had no hair on your
[ __ ] everybody Sandusky no I didn't
go to school in the 50s I could we
didn't shower in school why not the kids
shower in school now they still do Sam
know me showers and his little dirty
Birds don't shower at least like the
football team does I wasn't on the
football team while you were saying
you're a big t ballplayers
so there you are yeah I would sink after
deputy ball yeah and so the kids tease
you and act like you were baby or
something yeah I mean you're in there I
mean it wasn't like it was horrible but
then jebra at night when you're trying
to get to sleep you hear your parents
crying like what could we do you thought
they were lambs screaming out to the
barn but by the way you said this off
the air I'm gonna kind of out you here
I'm really taking a road gig on Mother's
Day yeah I mean we're going to LA on
Mother's Day yes yes we are
yeah your wife yeah I mean I'm also
gonna be gone on Father's Day it happens
yep you might as well you were you were
when it was conceived you don't think
[Laughter]
the kid looks like me that's not a DNA
test oh by the way I don't need a DNA
test yeah yeah my wife only has eyes for
me so it's not a concern she oh yeah
celebrate yeah of course it is well how
are you gonna celebrate what's out I
don't know phone call we celebrated the
day before I'm the guy eating cake
well sure Skype cake session I'll uh
text you at nine we'll set up the Skype
cake here we'll celebrate the day before
Wow it's Mother's Day on a Saturday I
can't believe we pulled it off mmm
yeah we're zipping out to LA across the
coast yeah I got w/e gig on Father's Day
so can I guess can I make one just
suggestion for you guys to drink you'll
love it
instead of taking a plane won't you guys
take motorcycles just across the country
you won't do it yeah
yeah Jim wanted a sidecar for him no I
want him on the back Jim he said he
wanted to sing born to be wild the
entire way from here to there and I
thought it's a good song I know but not
for the entire trip by the way the song
heavy that that song used the phrase
heavy metal I believe before any
newspaper or magazine dead why
no heavy metal with those RS personal
motorcycle though yeah heavy metal
Thunder yeah but after that cuz that was
kind of a hard rock song who do you
think this is like would be the first
metal bed you know Sabbath has
considered that the guys who started the
genre I guess because of the did the
dark side of the guitar I can't think of
who else corn no corn was way out ya
know they just make [ __ ] taste delicious
[Laughter]
no not just a next I'm a fan they're
kind of credited by guys like metallic
everyone kind of credits to hear that
sound you know like most band you go oh
that came from this and this that they
you know but when you hear that first
Sabbath record you're like well nothing
sounded like that yeah some of the riffs
were blues but it's the way he played
the guitar yeah I don't know I I know
people say blues I don't even hear it
some people say helter skelter is the
first metal song you know maybe give
everything to the Beatles maybe they're
they do but it might be right though cuz
they said McCartney couldn't write it
down in an event then I thought yeah I
mean not as heavy as yeah and and it's
only really like one song and they were
[ __ ] confused throughout I mean who
sings this song that's gonna set Manson
off and they're gonna know it's about a
roller coaster nearly really stupid is
that I would say I it's gotta be Sabbath
yeah I already said white zombie so what
do I know years you're like we were with
hip hop it all sounds to Sambia any kind
of way well you know he likes he likes
metal he likes [ __ ] zombie and then yeah
Jack white but you know I barlen Manson
say that you could lump up the entire
genre with like you know all their you
know they're just [ __ ] you just
slamming on guitars and thinking about
the devil yeah no you know rabbit rap
videos are close to you know they do
have a couple of subject they all sing
about possessions not all but a lot of
them doing it again a lot of mental
things about the same thing too
you can't make the argument that metal
or rock is as narrowly focused on one
subject as rappers you've also had
how many years of heavy metal' there's
only been three years of RIT no your job
is over 20-something years of okay Bob
it's not that it's it's new but they
just do because that's what sells you
know right now like like metal one
doesn't sound I mean hip-hop now doesn't
sound like hip-hop ten years ago no but
the subject matter is just like oh I
used to I think it used to be better I
used to I used to like with a yeah but
then I get back then it was all rap
battles and stuff - they were singing
about battling each other you know so a
lot of it hasn't changed guys I never
wanted this to go here I mean we were
having fun I don't ever want everything
to just become the black versus white
thing I mean I know this is the Trump
years but we got to come together
did you see Trump trying to hold hands
with his wife oh that was look will you
go with me now when I tell you that
those weren't having sex no they're not
I agree with that probably not you you
thought that they were maybe well you
know I said no I think she's mad at him
now because of all the cheating like
she's like [ __ ] you because all I think
yeah I think like you said he's
embarrassed her
he's it better humiliated her and she
knows it here's the thing it's only
because after it became president that
became I don't think she worried about
it before there's no one who were cared
it was a bad scene for her to become
first lady and I think she's done a good
job with it you know she doesn't wanna
be married the most hated guy in the
world because I'll get all I've said
this before all her friends she probably
and friends a lot of immigrants cuz
she's migrant and then these are the
people that hate him and she wants to be
like a socialite he doesn't leave the
house anymore it's gonna be a nightmare
right and now she turns into TV there
Trump is like let me knock that dandruff
on fear he was trying to go for a joke
would that have killed any other
president and yet but he does so much
[ __ ] every day
did it get a zero it got a zero a
shocked yeah people were shocked cuz
he's like Trump he's trying to be funny
he's trying to show how cool he in the
French guy are like how cool he and the
president of France are that they have
this like back and forth like we're just
buddies but he also always wants the guy
next to him to be slightly lower yeah it
was a control thing right it's a control
it's an alpha movies
ever like oh yeah he's gonna knock this
dandruff off my shoulder he's like here
let me knock the dandruff off your
shoulder because we want we want them to
see you but I don't think he's trying to
be a dick he'll even know he's doing it
no he doesn't it's in him mail
yeah like when he shakes people's hands
and he pulls him in real tight right
yeah you know any of you see him
dragging this guy by his hand yesterday
[ __ ] dragon I'm like like your dad
did you when you're in the [ __ ]
through the mall somebody's gonna hold
my hand pretty yeah Benny pulls his arm
in but I do think he realizes his joke
bomb I needed that comic thing of like
but you know seriously you know let's
listen to it yeah it's awful
mr. president they're all saying what a
great relationship we have and that's
naturally correct it's not fake news
finally it's not fake do so but we do
have a very special relationship folks I
mean that would be like this clip if it
were any other president would be played
through history for years and years
Dukakis sticking his head out of a tank
like people talk about it wasn't even
the president but there's an even safe
even find one where they're walking and
he's just pulling him like he's a little
kid but it was you know it would be like
if I came in here today and Sam was just
standing over me like you know remembers
no you sure was mugshot right you know I
mean I would have rung him kill but I
would have done a great joke there if he
said that to me would you put it back
put it back Troy put the video back I'll
see you Yuma but yeah like if I go to
like Ron in the break and go run no more
no more jokes at my expense right
remember whose name yeah whose names on
the microphone okay it says Sam there
okay so what I would have said you watch
way watch watch watch watch
what about your damn that's good [ __ ]
because the everyone has some amount of
dandruff it's very small but it does
exist there it is what but he realized
it Bobby my little piece lopunny is
perfect heel is perfect you know he just
do you think there was a moment on
realignment percent is very uncouth
thing that I'm doing he and they just
sat down he's gotta make him perfect he
is perfect like yeah you some shook a
little bit though he doesn't normally he
doesn't normally show like oh [ __ ]
that's not worry because he's got a
world leader that he thinks is his
friend and he maybe for a second he's
like oh [ __ ] I'm about to [ __ ] this up
you this is the last one it's almost
like teasing people yeah and you're like
you know I mean and say girl come on
this guy knows his why should pig not be
a good person all the sudden panic and
realize you went too far like what you
just and it bombed yeah it didn't kill
give me your shutter flash after a
dentist joke they're going like did you
just yeah did he just do that and you're
right this wouldn't like the first bush
or second but I would have never been
able to get away from never this didn't
even make the the head nose but I was
flop five six other things right I mean
even on this show we're do I mean do we
do the hand hold thing do we do the
dandruff thing that was yesterday yeah
Cosby we have any type of Cosby it's the
roots in the hands of the jury now yeah
so they tried him again well his defense
was how did how did she know that I
[ __ ] her if she was asleep defense
yeah he's right
medically speaking I think like all good
Camille looks good you think so
yeah yeah yeah Callaway you can't you
can't visualize going outside of that
marriage Kenya yeah there is another
time that this would have been 24-hour
and OJ Stephen OJ but you can't do
anything but Trump because it also has
got into so many worse directions or
just equally bad directions with Harvey
wine so many other things and this is
kind of older now yeah but this is like
at one time the most popular American
for like 10 years yeah and really one of
the best comics of all time
and this [ __ ] is going down it's
unbelief and again they locked me Mel up
and fili and this guy doesn't do at
night and this nothing nothing nothing
all because Meek Mill won't do a boys to
men song and shout out the judge he
should have I would he should have said
yes and they showed ister I know do it
still track Wow
yeah and like a good diss track I love a
good diss track and then mention how
expensive his shirt is oh my god yeah
this shirt cost more this uh this watch
cost more than your car yeah that's
great